your app won't always be in the
foreground but you still need to do
important background work like
downloading updates and synching with
your server now there are many existing
api's for this each with their own
particular use cases unfortunately when
these api's are used incorrectly we see
this happen to save power for users
Android has introduced many battery
saving features and recent releases
these features manage and balance the
power usage of apps as a developer you
need to work with these battery saving
features to ensure your background tasks
run across API levels this adds code
complexity but if you don't do this
properly you risk your background work
not running for all users this is where
the work manager library comes in work
manager provides a unified solution for
background work taking androids power
saving features and the users API level
into account it's backwards compatible
to API level 14 part of android jetpack
and it runs with or without Google Play
services these features and more make it
the recommended solution for most
background work on Android there are two
key attributes that make a task suitable
for work manager first that the task is
deferrable and second that the test
needs to be guaranteed to run deferrable
work is any task which is still useful
even if it's not run immediately so
sending analytic data to your server is
totally deferral work but sending an
instant message is not deferrable
guaranteed work means that the task will
run even if the app process is killed or
the device restarts so a great use case
for work manager would be backing up
pictures to a server this work can be
deferred but it should also be
guaranteed to run work manager can be
paired with other api's like firebase
Cloud messaging to trigger background
work so for example when there's data
ready to sync on your server you can use
an FCM message to notify your app and
then do the actual syncing with work
manager while work manager is powerful
background work isn't a
one-size-fits-all approach so for
example while I've been talking a lot
about background work when I don't mean
is background threading work manager
works in conjunction with but is not a
replacement for calling co-routines
thread pools or libraries like our
extraña
work manager is also not designed to
trigger work at an exact time for that
you're going to need to use an API like
a lar manager or start a foreground
service if your users expect your task
to happen immediately
a complete view of modern background
execution check out this blog post on
the Android developer blog which I've
linked below now let me show you how to
actually create and do some work let's
say that I want to upload a photo using
work manager first you define what your
task does using a worker like this one
all the code goes into the do work
method then you make a request to do
this work using a class called work
request as part of the work request you
can add constraints specify the input
and choose to run the work once or
periodically the work request is
basically a class for configuring when
and how your task will be run since this
is non-repeating work i'm gonna go ahead
and use a one-time work request I've
added a constraint here that it should
only do this upload when there's
actually Network finally this passes in
the URI of the photo as input data using
work manager's data object once you have
a work request you couldnt queue it by
calling work manager dot and queue and
well that's it at this point I know that
this photo will be uploaded at some
point of the future when the network
constraint is met even if the app is
closed or the phone restarts now let's
say that I want the option of updated
the UI when my work finishes I can use
the method get work info by ID live data
to get a work info live data the fact
that the work info is wrapped by live
data makes it observable if you haven't
used live data before you can read about
it in the documentation linked below
work info has all of the information
about the current state of my work
including the status of the work and the
optional output so back into work I
could return an output and then add this
live data observation code to my UI to
display the output when available so
what's going on behind the scenes when
you in cue work as mentioned work
manager is backwards compatible to API
level 14 and runs without Google Play
services to ensure this work manager
chooses between job scheduler and a
combination of alarmmanager and
broadcast receivers when running to
guarantee that the work will keep
running all of that information about a
queued work is kept in a work manager
bandaged database so that I can be
resumed if it's ever stopped now by
default worker does work off of the main
thread using an executor behind the
scenes if you want to handle threading
in some other way
there's rx worker and coercion worker
which are available out of the box or
for even more control you can make your
old worker class by extending listenable
worker and defining your exact threading
strategy one area where work manager
truly shines is when you create chains
of dependent work let's say that I want
to add a filter to multiple pictures
compress those pictures together and
then batch upload the compressed file to
share with the world
assuming you created all of your work
requests with the appropriate
constraints the code to create this
dependent shade of work looks like this
inq the work requests in the order that
I want them to run I've also include
these filter image work requests as a
list which causes them to run in
parallel work manager will take care of
passing through the output and input in
a chain so here it the output of these
filter work requests will be passed as
the input of the compressed work request
there is a ton more that you can do with
work manager you can specify things like
periodic work for work that needs to run
repeatedly unique work tagged work so
that you can query it or cancel related
work and back off policies for retrying
work for even more features tips and
tricks check out the working with work
manager talk linked below
so to summarize by using work manager
you can and cue one-off and periodic
tasks with constraints chain tasks with
input and output and run these 10 tasks
in parallel or sequentially display the
state of your tasks using observation
and customized work managers threading
strategy work manager does all of this
while handling complex compatibility
issues following system health best
practices and guaranteeing your work
will run if you're ready to get working
with work manager I've linked tons of
helpful documentation code labs
presentations and blog posts below happy
coding
you